отличие от списка дел туду вы знаете
наверное что очень много людей
используют простой список туда
что сделать начнем с того что обсудим
чем к этим планирование отличается от
списка дел туду список дел туду как вам
известно представляет собой обыкновенный
список где перечислены необходимые
задачи и ваши планы
каждым планирование же в отличии от
списка дел туду рассматривает процесс
планирования и исполнения как
непрерывный поток
когда вы строите систему планирования в
виде трубы или потока вы берете в расчет
фактор времени в то время как список дел
туду рассматривает время как жесткий
диск или как стакан с водой если бы
список дел был как стакан с водой или
как жесткий диск то вы могли бы просто
купить второй стакан или диск и
разгрузили бы себя но это ведь не так
отличие к 1 планирование от обычной
системы основанный на принципе списка
отдел состоит в следующем список дел
фокусируйся на том что нужно сделать
акользин планирования на том что сделать
сейчас
то есть чувствуете разницу там вот такой
список и непонятно что делать сейчас что
позже что когда и это деморализует
академ планирование вас фокусирую только
на том что сделать именно сейчас
список дел статистика статичен академ
планирования динамично вы в любое время
видите прогресс и продвижение ваших дел
когда вы смотрите на список дел не
понятно где вы находитесь вы не видите
прогресс каждой задачей а в каждом
планирование вы сразу это все видите
список дел подавляет когда у вас большой
список дел вы даже и не смейте к нему
приступить настолько это деморализует он
вас демотивирует и отсюда начинается
прокрастинация вы не знаете с какого
края начать это как если бы вы зашли в
комнату где царит полный бардак и в
которой надо на
вести порядок вы не знаете с чего начать
вы все время будете откладывать и
откладывать вам страшно будет приступить
к этому делу даже
каждом планирование же наоборот
мотивирует и вдохновляет потому что вы
сконцентрированы не на всей кучи дел а
только на том маленьком конкретном
участке что нужно сделать сейчас
благодаря этому вы видите как дела
постепенно тают и тает и вы четко
представляете когда вы закончите все
дела нет лучше мотиваторы для человека
чем видим и прогресс в делах
если взять за налога опять-таки эту
комнату с бардаком вы сразу заходите в
эту комнату и вместо того чтобы говорить
ай мне нужно навести порядок в этой
комнате вы говорите нет у меня нету цели
навести порядок в этой комнате все что
мне нужно сделать сегодня это очистить
условно только книжную полку на
следующий день вы заходите в эту комнату
или через какое-то время отдохнувшие
говорит моя цель очистить только этот
угол следующий заход моя цель очистить
этот угол и так вы сами не заметите как
вот эта большая куча бардака шаг за
шагом очень быстренько очистилась еще
одно большое отличие то что список дел
не показывает проблему вы не понимаете в
чем проблема в то время как кайден
планирование сразу выявляет проблемы
проблему вашем поведении в ваших целях
вашим планирование сама система помогает
выявлять все ваши проблемы и
совершенствоваться
котян это процесс непрерывного
постоянного совершенствования это именно
так переводится с японского языка
так вот как измерить вашу эффективной
спой с помощью кайзен планирования
[музыка]